You've learned that the API's explorer let's you
try out the API that your application exposes through
endpoints. Google uses the API's explorer in the
same way, to let you investigate the API that
are publicly available for the service that it
provides. For example let's consider Google's translation service. You
can go to translate.google.com to translate text from
one language to another, right in the browser. Hm,
wonder what lemon cake is in Spanish? Pastel de limon. I wonder if I said that
right? You can use the browser like this
to do translations. But you can also write applications
that do translations, using the translate API. You
can try out the translate API using the
APIs explorer. It's easy to find the API
explore for Google's public APIs. Just search for it.
Here it is, first result. When you go to the APIs Explorer. You see the list of
all the APIs that Google provides for developers to
use. You can search, or scroll down to the
translate API, and click it. Then you see the
functions that the translate API exposes. These are functions
that you, the developer, can use in your own
applications. 'Kay now it's your turn to try at
the translate API, using the APIs Explorer. So go to the APIs Explorer for the
translation service. To find out the meaning
of the name Gundega in English. Gundega is
our instructional designer for this course. You
could use the language.traslations.list function to translate text.
Set the target language to en, which stands
for English. When you figured out what Gundega
means in English, write it in this text
field here. When you submit a translation, you can
tell the translation service what the source language is.
Or you can let it try to figure out
the source language for itself. So, one more
thing for you to figure out, is what is
a source language for Gundega. When you've figured that
out, go ahead and check the appropriate check box.